[Musique]
croyez vous qu'il y ait de papa bûcheron
peco comptait bien sur vos droits
moi dans ma part il me manque
[Musique]
moi j'étais bat pas on attendait quand
tu ton enfant moi je suis athée bottes
mais moi j'ai beaucoup mieux à nous
le tablet os x ça n'existe pas de trop
vite et tout se passe bien
these mais inventer quelque chose
d'aussi important est aussi dangereux
bonjour monsieur bougon bonjour bonjour
vous avez l'air bien pressé je vais
m'entraîner outils avec mon fusil a fait
ch
[Musique]
pas mal pas mal du tout
et ça marche ça marche
le vol aller mais ça marche il va
peut-être essayer de
apparu des partenaires ne sont pas pas
cours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en auvergne a pas d'arbres mais en bail
on a en l'air n'y a pas d'arbres
meilleur bayonne à je ne sais pas je n'y
va plus vite que moi
drôle d'oiseau 40 ans de chasse j'ai
jamais vu ça
bon ben toutes les places y sont passés
pas prendre mon fusil je cours le
chercher lui ou pas le match du siècle
lui wah wah faisait parte à strophes un
saut est là tu as cru un seul spectacle
ou prendre un bain je reviens en plus je
suis là où ça je ne vois pas derrière
soi tous vos patates ou la prochaine
fois je mettrai une armure ce sera trop
lourd pour voler encore un problème
attention voilà le seul bouton
oui la bête le mot monstre est parti
vers pas ta vie
j'y cours ce sera lui ou moi le match du
siècle se sont enfin un fusil avec des
vraies balles je prends une décision
plus d'avions comme ça ce sera moins la
plus rapide
[Applaudissements]